oh god
my body is trembling oh my god
whoa whoa whoa look up here b
you know i'm just looking right here
[Music]
what are you thinking right now flying
through the air i'm just holding on man
i should probably be grateful that
they're hauling me out on a winch
instead of making me pull myself by hand
but i'm not
i'm just plain terrified you're almost
hitting me look
i hear your voice i can't i can't look
up you're right here buddy
a little bit more a little bit more
right there let's stop right there
that wasn't so bad right yes it was i'm
ready to clean
so i can get the crap out of here you
look great we're gonna get this done
brother
okay i'm so emotionally attached to you
right now mike
mike only gave me an hour to get out
here clean the skywalks glass floor
and get back on land time to put my
training into motion
even though all i want to do is get back
on solid ground
go up yep start ascending up there's a
lot of trust involved i have to trust
mike
i have to trust all the equipment that
i'm wearing
i have to trust the training that i did
and the hardest thing
i have to trust me and somehow push
myself up to the glass
attaboy what is that on my foot
you're touching me that's me
i can't get my grip up use your knee put
your knee up against that the structure
nice go and start cleaning bobby
whenever you're ready
time is ticking the one thing we never
practiced
only holding on to the rope with one arm
while cleaning the glass with the other
[Music]
i guess i didn't realize there would be
tourists here while i was cleaning it
hello folks i'm the idiot underneath
tell everybody you saw bobby bones
cleaning the bottom of the skywalk tell
one tell off
now the trick is you got to get all the
way to the back you got that far
corner to get to so we got to get on
those toes man you're relying too much
on this structure and your legs
reach out boom reach out boom okay i
need you to do that
it's tricky isn't it yeah
atta boy there you go reach out there
focus on the glass don't worry about
what's under you
all right i feel like i got my first
panel done all right now let's get that
second panel done
and we can get the hell out of here all
right the key is to reach right mike
kids three try to get on those toes
brother try to use those toes
you want to try to get that whole body
stretch
doing great man you're doing great one
more spot and i'll have
feel like i got it all right and after
that brother it's home
homeward bound
i got it oh my god i'm finally done with
the cleaning
but i'd forgotten about the scariest
part of all descending back down the
rope
and transferring to another line open up
that face plate and i can see perfectly
what you're doing man
nice and easy start to descend pull the
handle grab the brake
strand like i taught you pull the handle
and you'll start to drop
that a boy oh my god nice and easy
start to come down come on down is there
any chance this thing drops oh my god
you just
nope come on oh my god on yep just hold
it right there
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna re-hook
you on to your lowering system give me
some slack
i just want to get back to the land
honestly
okay transfer complete i'm still alive
but the winch moves slow
and i know time is running out all right
b is he on the cliff side
i can't freaking wait bye bye bye
oh my god great freaking job dude
earth i love you i cannot wait to be on
you again
and continue our relationship all right
i'm gonna come out and receive you all
right
give me your hand all right come on in
oh my god
all good ah oh crap bobby
i'm not there yet you're there buddy
you're there
proud of you bobby
oh so how are you feeling mentally
exhausted
emotionally fatigued and my body
is whooped i see how you guys you do
this all day and it's like you
really need some downtime i mean this is
the most grueling thing i have ever done
um also the scariest thing i've ever
done ever and i've done some pretty
freaking scary stuff not just appreciate
you guys mike appreciate you the team
i'm very excited about unhooking myself
and and getting on full land
right on bobby man i'm super proud of
you dude you overcame your fears you got
it done looked like a pass buddy
super good job man
[Music]
you